fm business
la librairie de l'écho
emmanuel lechypre bienvenue dans la
librairie de béco l'émission de bfm
business qui n'a qu'une ambition vous
donner envie de lire des livres
d'économies alors vous savez pas
d'émissions sur les livres son auteur
nous leur consacrons la première partie
de notre émission et puis nos deux
critiques attitré et jean marc daniel
christian chavagneux viendront vous
faire partager leurs coups de coeur et
leurs coups de gueule avant que nos
chroniqueurs du jour benaouda abdeddaïm
pour ses livres d'ailleurs et
aujourd'hui c'est le professeur david
murray qui sera notre bibliothécaire
pour les livres d'avant nous rejoigne
mais tout de suite on démarre avec
l'auteur
vous savez le 30 novembre c'est le début
de la coop 21 la grande conférence sur
le climat un événement qui a donné lieu
à une littérature mais littéralement
surabondante
alors le moins que nous devions c'était
bien de faire une sélection pour vous
proposer le meilleur de cette
littérature et donc sur la base de
critères relatifs à l'intelligence de
ses livres à leurs qualités pédagogiques
et bien nous nous avons fait notre
sélection et donc les heureux élus sont
là j'ai envie de dire
il s'agit pour le premier de jean marc
jancovici bonjour jean marc 15 jean-marc
vous publiez dormez tranquilles jusqu'en
2100 et autre malentendu sur le climat
et l'énergie vous attaquez à pas mal
d'idées reçues sur le sujet vous êtes
enseignant consultant fondateur de la
société carbone 4 et président du shift
project le chef project en deux mots je
suis project c'est un endroit où on
essaye de réfléchir à ce que veut dire
une économie décarbonée avec les acteurs
qui ont tout à y gagner et avec des
propositions un peu concrètes merci est
notre deuxième invité c'est y va eckland
le professeur il varie claude
mathématicien économiste vous avez
présidé l'université de paris dauphine
et vous publiez vous aussi chez odile
jacob
le syndrome de la grenouille je suis
très heureux de vous avoir il va réclame
parce que vous avez aussi écrit beaucoup
d'autres livres notamment sur la théorie
des jeux sur lesquels j'ai beaucoup
souffert plus jeune mais j'ai aussi
appris beaucoup
alors on commence avec vous jean marc
jancovici vous dites à propos de
l'énergie
c'est vraiment le domaine qui a façonné
le monde
aucun autre aucun autre domaine a
façonné le monde comme l'énergie le
décollage économique du 19e c'est
l'énergie la fils de
8 c'est l'énergie par exemple ce que moi
j'appelle l'énergie en fait c'est ce que
beaucoup d'économistes appelle le
progrès technique
le progrès technique c'est quoi c'est
d'avoir progressivement appelé à notre
rescousse un nombre croissant de
machines qui se sont mis à suppléer nos
bras et aux jambes et à faire à vitesse
accélérée un certain nombre de choses
qui sont devenus de plus en plus
accessible qu'il s'agisse de tasses de
chaises ou de smartphones cette énergie
en fait c'est la nourriture des machines
l'énergie en physique c'est la
transformation par définition donc plus
on a d'énergie plus on peut transformer
et comme nous notre corps il a une
capacité limitée à absorber l'énergie
c'est à dire manger pour bouger nos bras
et aux jambes
on a créé d'autres objets qui sont
capables de le faire à notre place
cappel des machines et qui a le plus
elles sont rouges et on peut les faire
de plus en plus grosse plus elle peuvent
absorber l'énergie et transformer
l'environnement donc l'énergie en
quantité croissante donne de manière
extrêmement simple le pib croissant d'un
pays alors le problème c'est
qu'effectivement vous dites il ya un
phénomène qui s'est produit en 2005
c'est la production mondiale qui cessent
d'augmenter de pétrole pour le pétrole
bien sûr on augmente plus la production
de pétrole et vous dites indépendamment
du stock de réserve et 2 contres
découvrira comme réserves dans les
années à venir
on ne doit pas cette production et donc
si on n'augmente pas cette production
ont fait le lien que vous faites avant
ça veut dire qu'il n'y aura pas de
croissance demain je vais prendre un
parallèle imaginons vous ayez un compte
en banque dans lequel vous avez des
intérêts qu'ils produisent chaque année
de plus en plus d'argent sur le compte
en banque mais que pour une raison
quelconque vous soyez limitée dans vos
capacités à retirer de l'argent de son
compte
qu'est ce qui compte vraiment le fait
qu'ils aient plein d'argent sur le
compte ou le fait que l'on vous empêche
d'en profiter en quantité croissante
mais les réserves c'est ça en fait les
réserves c'est le compte en banque mais
il se trouve que ces réserves elles sont
de plus en plus difficiles à sortir de
la banque
c2c du pétrole qui est plus en plus
difficiles à sortir du sol le problème
c'est pas les réserves c'est le tuyau en
fait un aliment est en fait si vous vous
intéressez à la quantité totale
d'hydrocarbures qu'on peut extraire du
sol en dépensant moins de 20 kilowatts
heure pour sortir un kilowattheure y en
a des quantités considérables mais si
vous regardez ce que ça signifie en
pratique de le sortir aujourd'hui
eh bien le flux annuel d'extraction donc
la production annuelle on va
dire vous n'arrivez plus à l'augmenter
parce que c'est devenu trop dur et on ne
s'en rend pas compte parce que dans les
statistiques qui sont publiés par les
organismes de place on agrège du pétrole
et d'autres trucs qui sont pas du
pétrole mais quand on regarde le ferais
pétrole il a cessé de croître depuis
et comme on est toujours plus nombreux
autour de la table de repas c'est à dire
qu'il ya les émergents qui émergent et
qui en consomment de plus en plus et
bien les pays de l' ocde
anciennement industrialisés en ont de
moins en moins alors il y a ce contexte
pétrolier énergétique et il y a aussi
cette problématique du réchauffement
alors pour bien comprendre parce que bon
on parle tous du réchauffement de deux
degrés ces fameux deux degrés mais deux
degrés c'est une moyenne
ça veut ça veut pas dire grand chose ça
ne reflète finalement la situation de
personnes puisque c'est une moyenne
et ça c'est quand même pas très lisible
du coup une des choses que j'essaye
d'expliquer dans ce bouquin c'est du
reste le chapitre qui a donné son titre
à l'ouvragé
c'est que quand on vous parle de deux
trois ou quatre ou cinq peu importe
degrés en 2100 ça ne fait peur à
personne pour deux raisons d'abord parce
que 2100 on sera tous morts et nos
enfants sont morts donc c'est tellement
lointain que on en a d'autres problèmes
à plus court terme par exemple de ne
soigner mathoux et puis la deuxième
chose c'est que quand on pense quelques
degrés de moyenne
on confond avec quelques degrés de
variation de la température
là où on est or là tout de suite si dans
la pièce où on est la température varie
de devrait il leur est strictement
inverse voilà on passe à travers
est ce qu'on n'arrive pas à comprendre
c'est que la moyenne elle représente une
variation beaucoup plus ample c'est un
peu comme les notes de votre enfant au
collège ou au lycée
si elles varient de deux points d'une
composition sur l'autre ça veut rien
dire
par contre si la moyenne du lycée
varient de deux points d'un mois sur
l'autre en ce sens ça veut dire quelque
chose
alors justement quand on combine cette
problématique énergétique
cette problématique réchauffement
auditifs il faut pas se tromper sur la
nature de problèmes que ça va créer le
problème c'est pas c'est pas l'homme
c'est pas nous vous dites les problèmes
qui seront créés par ces problématiques
énergétiques et climatiques
ce sont des problèmes économiques
géopolitiques et aussi des problèmes
démocratiques parce que la démocratie
est allée de pair en fait avec la
croissance
alors je dis oui effectivement que
l'adema alors gmail hypothèse il ya
d'autres choses sur lesquelles je suis
plus affirmatif mais là c'est une
hypothèse de travail qui me semble
séduisante qui est de dire que la
démocratie de masse au fait que
l'essentiel de la population mondiale
maintenant quasi vivant démocratie c'est
l'enfant de l'énergie abondante
parce que ça permet finalement de créer
un univers non contraint un univers en
expansion est un univers non contraints
et dans un univers non contre 1 c'est
plus facile de faire des progrès c'est
de les réaliser
c'est plus facile d'assurer une forme
d'égalité c'est plus facile d'assurer
une forme de liberté
si le monde et pas contre n'importe qui
peut s'établir entrepreneurs et avoir
une chance de succès donc c'est quelque
chose qui est consubstantielle à mon
avis à la démocratie la croissance qu'on
a connu jusqu'à maintenant
et effectivement je me pose la question
de savoir si ça va résister au fait que
le monde devienne contraint alors les
conséquences géopolitiques c'est quoi
par exemple le printemps arabe ou ce
qu'on est en train de vivre ce qu'on
vient de vivre à paris à une semaine
tout ça c'est des conséquences
indirectes de énergie et climat et ça
fait l'objet d'un plan chapitre du
bouquin où j'explique que le printemps
arabe ou avec la syrie au sens large a
été déterminé par un certain nombre
d'éléments qui puisent leurs racines
dans l'énergie et le climat
d'abord le premier élément qui puise ses
racines dans l'énergie c'est qu'on a
découpé des frontières tout droite
indépendamment des cultures des peuples
des religions parce qu'il fallait se
partager le pétrole donc ça c'est la
création des puissances occidentales
dont pétrole une première fois pétrole
une deuxième fois c'est la production
mondiale s'arrête de croître en 2005
crise économique puis financière les
touristes eux restent chez eux donc pour
des pays comme la tunisie et l'egypte ça
les prix de recettes pétrole une
troisième fois
la syrie a passé son pic de production
en 2002 depuis la production de pétrole
décline en c'est sa principale recettes
à l'exportation donc moins de pétrole
exporté par la syrie
moins d'argent pour compenser les
importations or tous ces pays hélas ces
changements climatiques une première
fois sont structurellement importateurs
de céréales désormais à cause de la
sécheresse endémique qui survit dans le
tas qui survient dans le bassin
méditerranéen et en 2010 il ya eu un
choc sur le prix mondial des céréales à
cause du changement climatique une
deuxième fois de la canicule en russie
qui a privé le marché mondial
de 20 % des quantités disponibles alors
venons en maintenant aux solutions ou ce
qu'on croit être les solutions par
rapport à ces problématiques
énergétiques et climatiques les
renouvelables
est ce que ce sera la solution à notre
défi climatique les renouvelables c'est
les énergies qu'on a quitté
historiquement pour passer aux fossiles
les premiers bateaux avancé au vent les
premiers les premières fort je
fonctionnais au bois etc
et si on l'a fait dans ce sens a réparé
dans l'autre c'est que les énergies
fossiles avait des avantages en termes
de densité de puissance et de facilité
d'extraction qui les rendent bien
supérieur tant qu'il y en a plein et que
ça perturbe pas le climat il ya aucune
raison de se passer des énergies
fossiles c'est beaucoup plus facile à
utiliser donc revenir aux énergies
renouvelables c'est quelque chose qui va
globalement affaiblir la productivité du
travail si je le dis de manière un peu
large c'est pour ça qu'on n'est pas très
pressé de le faire soit dit en passant
moi je pense qu'on va devoir le faire
pour partie mais on n'est pas très
pressé de le faire est ce que vous dites
ce qui compte c'est l'efficacité
comparée des investissements dans toutes
les sources d'énergie et vous citer par
exemple la comparaison avec le nucléaire
en gros pour une même production
d'énergie annuelle
il faut installer trois ou quatre fois
plus de puissance en éolien connu clair
paris un réacteur en gros il produit en
moyenne sur l'année à 70% de sa pleine
puissance voire 90 aux états unis une
éolienne
elle produit en moyenne sur l'année à
20% de sa pleine puissance et un panneau
solaire en moyenne sur l'année ces dix à
vingt ça dépend où il est installé pour
cent de sa pleine puissance
donc il faut installer beaucoup plus de
puissance quand on prend alors les
énergies renouvelables entendons bien
c'est pas juste l'éolien et le solaire
mais c'est souvent ceux celles là dont
on parle en premier celle hydraulique
est beaucoup plus important dans le
monde mais pour sa part des montagnes
donc si vous êtes norvégien vous pouvez
faire plein de choses avec des
renouvelables
et si vous êtes belge n'a pas de chance
alors vous revenez aussi sur l'exemple
allemand qu'on cite quand même souvent
comme référence en garde et ils ont
réussi à développer des énergies
renouvelables et vous dites quand même
les résultats ne sont pas à la hauteur
de ce que prétendent les zélateurs de ce
modèle ce que les allemands ont dit
quand ils ont commencé à faire leur
tournant énergétique la première chose
qu'ils ont dit les français l'ont passé
en tête c'est d'abord qu'il voulait se
débarrasser du nucléaire
or si vous remplacez du nucléaire qui ne
fait pas de co2 part des renouvelables
qui ne font pas de co2 ça à plein des
faits mais pas celui de toucher au co2
donc si vous regardez le co2 par
kilowattheure électrique aujourd'hui en
allemagne il est à peu près là où il
était il ya dix ans et l'allemagne est
toujours aussi dépendante des énergies
fossiles importées si vous regardez les
émissions par personne en allemagne
elles sont aujourd'hui de l'ordre de 10
tonnes de co2 par personne et par an
alors que les français sont à 6 et les
allemands étaient déjà à 10 tonnes de
co2 par personne et par an avant les
derniers 22 en ordre de grandeur
donc ce qu'ils ont fait avec leurs
tournant énergétique c'est qu'ils ont
investi 350 milliards d'euros
c'est à dire la même chose que la
réflexion à 9 du parc nucléaire français
350 milliards d'euros avec ça ils ont
accru la part renouvelables dans
l'électricité de 22% sont passés de 86
une partie de cette électricité il l'a
consommée à la place du nucléaire donc
ça change rien sur le co2 et une partie
ils l'exportent de manière fatale quand
il ya du vent au quand y'a du soleil en
demandant à leurs voisins de bien
vouloir gérer à leur frais cet afflux
intempestives d'électricité
voilà ce qu'ils ont fait alors vous
pointez aussi le paradoxe du charbon en
gros c'est quand même lui l'ennemi du
climat le principal ennemi du climat et
pourtant c'est lui aussi dont la
production croît le plus vite
quand on regarde la consommation
d'énergie mondiale sur les 14 dernières
années 2000 2014
le charbon a augmenté de 30 fois plus
que le solaire est dix fois plus que
l'éolien donc parler du solaire et de
l'éolien c'est l'arbre qui cache la
forêt ce qui s'est vraiment passé dans
le monde sur les 14 dernières années
c'est pas du tout les sort des
renouvelables
l'extraordinaire essor du charbon
aujourd'hui en france vous avez 63 on en
parle suffisamment gigawatts de
puissance nucléaire installée prendre et
l'électricité
le parc mondial de centrales à charbon
tenez vous bien ses 1800 gigawatts donc
63 j avais de nucléaire en france 1800
gigawatts de centrales à charbon dans le
monde
si on veut respecter la trajectoire des
deux degrés essence et de la fille toute
simple qui nous y amène ses 1800
gigawatts
il faut totalement les mettre à la
ferraille dans les 30 ans qui viennent
totalement alors est-ce qu ia jean marc
jancovici un autre choix rationnel
aujourd'hui que d'être à la fois écolo
et pro nucléaire là aussi on n'a pas à
céret se rappeler sur les ondes
françaises
le giec qui fait l'évaluation de la
littérature scientifique sur la question
a dit mais on s'est bien gardé de le
répéter que sans le nucléaire
la probabilité pour qu'on arrive à
contenir le changement climatique dans
des zoos n'a à peu près gérable était à
peu près nulles dit autrement ça ne
suffit pas mais faire sans accroît le
risque d'avoir de plus en plus de guerre
de déstabilisation de krach économique
et de choses beaucoup plus désagréable
que le problème des déchets nucléaires
la croissance verte ce thème qu'on
emploie un peu à toutes les sauces ses
illusions ou c ou c ou c ce qui nous
attend demain vous pouvez
malheureusement désormais en europe
enlevé l'adjectif est à ce moment c'est
ce qui nous attend sarr a déjà commencé
en lien avec ce qu'on disait tout à
l'heure sur le pétrole
l'approvisionnement énergétique de tous
les pays ocde a commencé à baisser en
2007 en europe comme ailleurs et la
production industrielle
arnaud montebourg ou pas a commencé à
baisser dans tous les pays de l' ocde
depuis 2007
à deux exceptions près l'allemagne à
cause de son solde exportateur et les
états unis parce qu'ils ont eu un petit
pitch d'énergie avec leur gaz et leur
pétrole de schiste mais globalement dans
la zone la production industrielle
décline depuis je ne vois pas de raison
que ça s'arrête puisque le pétrole va
continuer à décliner dans la zone ocde
le gaz décline en europe puisque la mer
du nord est en déclin donc je pense que
malheureusement il va falloir inventer
un avenir radieux
sans croissance et quand je dis sans
croissance c'est pas avec un pib
constance et malheureusement je pense
avec un pib des croissants alors merci
jean marc
vous avez évoqué cette question de d'un
problématique du temps long on y revient
avec vous il va eckland
c'est un peu votre point de départ alors
d'abord ce syndrome de la grenouille
expliquez-nous de quoi il s'agit
exactement ben c'est quelque chose qu'on
m'avait appris quand j'étais au canada
on me disait si tu veux faire cuire une
grenouille
pourquoi on veut faire une cure
grenouille c'est notre affaire il ne
faut pas la jeter dans l'eau bouillante
parce que l centre est en danger il ya
traitement d'urgence elle ses muscles
sous contrat quel sort immédiatement ce
qu'il faut faire au contraire si tu la
mets deux une eau tiède
tu es lève lentement la température
arnaud grenouille allait bien
a été terrassé mu se décontracter de
mieux en mieux mais quand tu commences à
s'inquiéter
eh bien il est déjà trop tard alors
c'est cette idée vraiment qui ne
semblent symboliques du changement
climatique qui se passe en ce moment
parce que chaque année est un petit peu
plus chaude que l'année précédente un
petit peu ce drame du changement graduel
en fait jean manuel chaque année d'un
petit peu plus chaude que vient des
précédentes m'enfin c'est pas tellement
grave il ya un peu plus chaud c'est un
peu plus chaud c'est un peu plus chaud
et les générations et il faut bien
rendre compte aussi nous rendre compte
aussi que les gens les jeunes maintenant
ils n'ont pas connu les étés les étés
les divers de 1950 donc leurs éléments
de comparaison
c'est ce qu'ils ont connu en l'an 2000
et cetera donc il y a également un
déplacement du but ce qui compte ce
qu'on considère comme des températures
qu'on considère comme normal s'élève à
peu tout le temps donc il n'y a aucun
sentiment d'urgence aucune raison de
faire quelque chose maintenant
et le résultat c'est que on ne fait rien
c'était est un genre de procrastination
gros concrètement dès l'instant où on a
un problème qui nous mène sur l'échelle
de deux ou trois générations finalement
la génération actuelle s'en fout là bas
il ya aussi cet autre problème le choix
le changement climatique cumule tous les
dix toutes les difficultés de la tyrie
économique par exemple ça c'est
complètement nouveau en économie on nous
demande actuellement de sauge de prendre
des décisions dans les conséquences qui
tireront en conséquent dans 100 ou 200
ans
mais dans son eau de 100 ans comme on
l'a dit nous ne serons plus là les
enfants seront plus là et il n'y a pas
d'intérêt personnel à ça oui mais alors
justement alors voix passons en revue
les mais les mécanismes pour essayer de
finalement de dalles et de réguler
s'agit au moins dire alors d'abord le
marché est ce que la solution peut venir
du libre jeu des forces de la
concurrence pour régler ce problème
climatique dont la coquille non elle ne
peut pas c'est une très vieille histoire
d'ailleurs ce n'est pas neuf
savait-il par adams n'était pas réparé
par d'autres le climat est ce qu'on
appelle un bien public
si vous voulez on parle du prix du
carbone
le problème est différent si vous voulez
on parle du prix du bifteck
le prix du bifteck c'est clair si je
veux manger du bifteck je paye le
bifteck le mange si c'est trop cher je
n'achète pas le bifteck et il est là
mais le carbone
personne n'en veut du carbone donc le
prix du carbone ça veut dire quoi ça
veut dire qu'on va mener des dommages et
parce que on va me donner quelque chose
qui va me nuire c'est par un prix c'est
pas un prix de marché ça donc on peut à
des constructions artificielles en faire
un prix de marché
mais c'est ça le marché du des émissions
donner un prix aux émissions ça vous
paraît pas une solution rennais lors on
peut donner un prix alors se sont un peu
ce qui est important par exemple et de
limiter les éditions alors maintenant si
vous n'aviez pas uniquement le marché
vous comprenez bien que les forces du
marché n'amèneront personne n'a limité
des émissions je veux dire chacun
produit d'un chacun aimait parce qu'elle
a toujours intérêt à émettre davantage
pour qu'on dise on va imposer un prix de
marché déjà d'une intervention de l'état
voilà déjà les t'arriver 10 messieurs
dames on arrive et c'est un peu comme la
réserve américaine vous savez le
prennent à rêver de la réserve
américaine disait mon rôle c'est de
retirer le la bouteille de punch quand
les gens commencent à lui retrouvé on
ferme le bar à 3 heures du matin
cette façon qu'il ya un prix de marché
c'est ce truc le gouvernement a donc
déjà eu cette intervention du
gouvernement
ce n'est plus le marché a maintenant
donc c'est une des outils d'action et je
pense qu'il est beau mais il ya
plusieurs
alors lorsque vous dites la rationalité
elles n'existent pas en fait par exemple
vous prenez l'exemple des baleines on
vous dit
la rationalité voudrais que les gens qui
finalement vivre la pêche à la baleine
cet intérêt à ce que les baleines se
reproduit s'est durablement au rhône et
on tue la ressource oui ça c'est une
expérience grandeur nature qui a été
fait ça c'est que vous avez vécu parce
été professeur au canada en dans les
années soixante dix il était question de
conserver les baleines et l'industrie
baleinière disait mais regardez nous est
ce qu'on à l'aide d'un pc avant tu es la
poule du nord on vit des baleines c'est
pas nous qui sommes habitués
et ça c'est le jeu du marché mais les
collègues à main bon couvert à l'époque
avait fait un calcul sur le dos d'une
enveloppe
et il a des comparer deux stratégies la
première consiste à gérer le stock de
baleines
la deuxième consiste à créer tout le
monde aujourd'hui à mettre l'argent à la
banque et la deuxième stratégie et est
bien supérieur parce que l'argent se
reprenait beaucoup plus vite dans le
compte en banque où se reproduisent à
l'époque que les baleineaux dans la mer
donc ça et c'est à cause de ça qu'on à
réguler la pêche à la baleine alors si
ce n'est pas le marché
on peut faire entrer en scène les
économistes pour essayer de régler le
problème est là il faut faire intervenir
une notion que vous évoquez dans votre
livre qui est la notion de taux
d'intérêt écologique
le taux d'intérêt c'est un peu la valeur
du futur expliquez-nous ce que c'est que
ce taux d'intérêt écologique
bon bah écoutez le taux d'intérêt c'est
effectivement la valeur du futur c'est à
dire que si pour un taux d'intérêt de
si vous mettez un taux d'intérêt de 10%
1 dommages évalués à un million d'euros
dans son temps ça vous sert aujourd'hui
un ton très tôt derrière élevé tu le
futur bien maintenant là est la
recherche qui est fait pas dessus votre
rang d'icône et midi il faut quand même
distinguer des biens qui sont des biens
de consommation qui sont ceux dont on
vient de parler il ya monsieur jancovici
etc sur des biens qu'on peut produire à
volonté à des ordinateurs on peut en
produire tant qu'on veut tant qu'à
d'énergie il faut le distinguer ce genre
de biens de biens qui sont en croissance
de biens qui sont plutôt en décroissance
parce que des arbres on ne va pas en
produire indéfiniment ils peuvent se
produire ses limites et un arbre de même
ses limites et les baleines entend
produire un film donc entre des biens
qui sont susceptibles de produire côté
limité et des billets sont limitées par
nature il ne faut pas appliquer le même
taux d'intérêt et donc des projets
d'investissement dans la forêt d'un
média naturelles doivent ont plus
d'importance et doivent être taxés à un
taux d'intérêt plus faibles pour évaluer
pardon un taux d'intérêt plus faibles
que des biens qui sont des biens de
consommation que pour produire autant
qu'on veut mais ce taux d'intérêt
écologique aujourd'hui si lille et l'uil
il n'est pas nul c'est à dire que quand
vous a fait un investissement dans
l'environnement personnes de 10 100
millions dans son temps ça vous semble
mais aujourd'hui c'est qu'il est trop
faible qu'il est passé incitatif ça veut
dire que les taux d'intérêt que l'on
prend ce sont les taux du marché il
faudrait des taux plus faibles mais les
taux de marché voire des taux négatifs
en est en train de parler de taux
négatifs penser que ça n'existait pas
mais on l'a vu récemment alors sur la
politique climatique vous dites aussi
c'est le royaume du passager clandestin
oui le pot il va parce que le problème
fondamental du du réchauffement
climatique
voyez deux degrés eh bien on est là on
négocie et puis nous sommes tous la
halle toutes les nations gas en relation
sur la terre aux idées du degré savez
0,02 degré chaque pour moi je vais faire
des efforts pour 0,02 degré après je
rentre chez moi et expliquer aux
français on va se serrer la ceinture
pour 0,02 degré non les gens rentrent
chez eux et se disent 0,02 degré moi je
fais rien que personne s'en apercevra
d'ailleurs ce seront les
autres qui feront et la selle pour un
peu un problème classique de l'action
collective 1
le problème c'est que quand j'évalue les
efforts que je sais en france il faut
pas et vale il faudrait compter non
seulement le bénéfice que ça a pour les
français mais le bénéfice tard pour les
chinois et les oui c'est ça le drame
aussi de ses politiques climatiques dire
que il ya toujours ceux qui ont
l'impression de faire des efforts pour
les autres qui n'en font pas partie du
passager c'est le principe de passager
clandestin
l'idéal toujours c'est de ne pas faire
d'effort soi-même et de profiter des
efforts des autres bons alors
concrètement qu'est ce qu'on fait pour
s'en sortir il va réclamer ce qu'on
change sur quel levier on actionne pour
que l'on prenne enfin en compte ces
problématiques climatiques
aujourd'hui bon alors il y à des mesures
techniques si j'ose dire le taux
d'intérêt écologique l'énergie nucléaire
mais je pense que le problème va plus
loin je pense que les gouvernements ne
sont pas les bons acteurs
les gouvernements ne sont pas ceux qui
doivent négocier le climat parce que
numéro 1
leur horizon est beaucoup trop court il
songe à un an deux ans et est numéro 2
ils sont dans le passager clandestin
le gouvernant français qui s'occupa les
chinois négocier alors je pense que le
recours fallait être soit des organismes
internationales comme l'onu soit les
citoyens c'est à dire que je pense pour
vous qu'on vous regardez autour de vous
je pense que les individus sont plus
concernés que les états je pense que les
municipalités sont plus concernés que
vous dites qu'il faut que l'homme change
aussi à jeudi qu' il faut je dis qu'il
faut à des mouvements citoyens
on peut faire des boycotts par exemple
on peut poser côté des entreprises ça se
fait qu'ils travaillent match si vous
voulez le problème n'est pas uniquement
inconnu economics est un problème
éthique et il commence à y avoir des
mouvements ce sens la dernière
encyclique pontificale par exemple
disait exactement ça allait le mot de la
fin jean marc jancovici
j'ai tout à fait d'accord en fait il
faut trouver des organismes
transnationaux ou supra nationaux qui
ont un effet de levier sur une partie de
la solution
le pape est un très bon exemple la
religion ces transnationales ou
supranationales
je vais en donner quelques autres
puisque ici on parle d'économie le
comité de stabilité financière qui a été
instauré après la crise
s'il dit je vais faire des stress tests
sur les portefeuilles d'investissement
et ceux qui seront trop riches en
carbone
ils vont se prendre des mesures
prudentielles plus sévères c'est pas du
tout une blague arrivé dans le g20 a
donné un mandat au conseil de stabilité
financière pour qu'ils s'en occupent
si le comité de bâle dit les banques qui
prêtent à des activités qui détruisent
le climat il ya un besoin de couvertures
en fonds propres plus élevés pour ses
banques
ça va avoir un vrai impact donc en fait
c'est ces endroits là qu'il faut
identifier dans le monde économique est
ailleurs parce que c'est là que la vraie
vie grâce aux jouets merci beaucoup
merci jean marc jancovici ainsi à vous
merci y vas y vas réclame on se retrouve
dans quelques instants avec nos
critiques